until recently the small city of sehana
in the southeastern state of sao paulo
was no different to the rest of brazil
with covid19 infections spreading at
alarming rates
hospitals on the brink of collapse and
not enough vaccines
for its population of 45 000
that changed in february when sehana was
chosen
for a pioneer study to discover what
would happen if
every adult was vaccinated
four months later ninety-seven percent
of all adults have received two doses of
the coronavac vaccine
produced by china and sao paulo's
institute and sahana has become an oasis
of health
in a country with the world's second
largest coven 19 death toll
the results of the experiment were
announced on monday
this unprecedented study shows that the
number of deaths dropped 95
the number of hospitalizations dropped
86
and the number of people who were
infected with the virus and felt
symptoms
dropped by 80 percent this is good news
for brazil and the world
the study shows that inoculating 75
of the adult population is enough to
control the coronavirus
even the more aggressive p1 variant
which first appeared in the brazilian
city of manaus
children up to 18 years old were not
vaccinated
but the study found that they had been
indirectly protected
by the wide scale inoculation program
and could return to schools safely
santa's success story is certainly good
news but not a guarantee that the rest
of brazil will
follow in its footsteps president jain
bolsonaro has downplayed the virus from
the start
and criticized the chinese vaccine
promoted by
sao paulo's governor who is a strong
contender
in the 2022 presidential elections
meanwhile another city of sao paulo
state is vaccinating
all residents between 18 and 60 years
old
but the study in botocatu is being
carried out with the astrazeneca vaccine
produced by oxford and brazil's fucrus
institute
so it's absolutely vital for all of us
across the world that we have as much
data as possible and the exp
and and the research that is being done
in botocateu over the next months
is going to be really vital for that
scientific sharing
an increase of knowledge in the world
about how the astrazeneca vaccine
operates
for many brazilians receiving a vaccine
is still a long way off
so far only 10 percent of the population
has been fully inoculated monika yanakiv
al jazeera rio de janeiro